we're told the graph of y equals 2 to
the x is shown below so that's the graph
it's an exponential function which of
the following is the graph of y is equal
to negative 1 times 2 to the x plus 3
plus 4. and they give us 4 choices down
here and before we even look closely at
those choices
let's just
let's just think about what this would
look like if it was transformed into
that and you might notice that what we
have here this y that we want to find
the graph of is a transformation of this
original one how do we transform it well
we replaced x with x plus 3 then we
multiplied that by negative 1 and then
we add 4. so let's take it step by step
so this is y equals 2 to the x what i
want to do next is let's graph y is
equal to 2 to the x plus 3 power
well if you replace x with x plus 3
you're going to shift the graph to the
left the left to the left by three and
that might be a little bit
counter-intuitive but when we actually
think about some points it'll hopefully
make some sense here for example over in
our original graph when x is equal to
zero
y is equal to one
well how do we get y equal how do we get
y equal one for our new graph for this
thing right over here well to get y
equals one here the exponent here still
has to be zero so that's going to happen
at x equals negative three so that's
going to happen at x equals negative 3
y is equal to 1. so notice we shifted
to the left
by 3.
likewise in our original graph when x is
2 y is 4.
well how do we get y equals 4 in our in
this thing right over here well for y to
be equal to 4
this exponent here needs to be equal to
2 and so for this exponent to be equal
to 2
because 2 squared is 4 for this exponent
to be equal to 2 x is going to be equal
to negative 1. so when x is equal to
negative 1
y is equal to 4. when x is equal to
negative 1 y is equal to 4. notice we
shifted to the left by
we shifted to the left by three
and so this thing which wasn't isn't our
final graph that we're looking for is
going to look something like
it's going to look something like
something like
like that which shifted its y equals 2
to the x shifted to the left by 3.
now let's figure out what the graph of
now let's multiply this expression times
negative 1. notice we're slowly building
up to our goal so now let's figure out
the graph of y is equal to negative one
times two to the x plus three
well here when y equals two to the x
plus three if we multiply that times
negative one whatever y we had we're
gonna have the negative of that so
instead of when x is equal to negative 3
having positive 1 when x equals negative
3 you're going to have negative 1. we
multiply by negative 1.
when x is equal to negative 1 instead of
having 4 you're going to have negative
4.
so our graph is going to be flipped over
it's flipped over the x-axis
and it's going to look
something
something like this and this is not a
perfect drawing but it'll give us a
sense of things and we can look at which
of these graphs match up to that and
then finally
we want to add that 4 there
so we want to figure out the graph of y
equals negative 1 times 2 to the x plus
plus 4. so we want to take what we just
had and shift it up by four so instead
of this being a negative one right over
here this is going to be a
negative one plus four is three
instead of this being a negative four
negative four plus 4
is 0.
instead of our horizontal asymptote
being at y equals 0 our horizontal
asymptote is going to be at y equals 4.
so it's going to look like
let me draw i could do a better job than
that our horizontal asymptote is going
to be right over there so our graph is
going to look something like
we're going to look something like
something like this we just shifted that
red graph up by four
shifted it up by
shifted it up by four and we have a
horizontal asymptote at y equals four so
let's look at which of these choices
match that
so choice a right over here has a
horizontal asymptote y equals four but
it is shifted
on the horizontal direction
inappropriately in fact it looks like it
might have not been shifted to the left
so we can rule this one out so let's
rule that one out
this one over here
well this one just this one the this one
approaches our asymptote as x increases
so that's not right it should approach
our asymptote as x decreases so we rule
that one out
choice c
looks like what we just graphed
horizontal asymptote at x equals four
when x equals negative three y is equal
to three that's what we got when x is
equal to negative one y is equal to zero
so this looks right and you can even try
those points out
and so
we like choice c
and d is clearly off